un petit peu loin
voilà c'est ça des frappes intenses de
la rapidité à 30 ans Philippines Pereira
Lopez à une nouvelle fois fait briller
les couleurs de son club le Gant d'or de
Houilles après un titre mondial en 2022
le 2 septembre dernier livre linoise
membre de l'équipe de France a remporté
le titre de championne d'Europe assault
de boxe française dans la catégorie des
moins de 65 kg la compétition c'est
plutôt bien passée grâce à l'expérience
que j'avais eu déjà en septembre 2022
sur les championnats du monde j'avais un
peu moins de stress ou alors j'apprends
à mieux gérer au fur et à mesure aussi
ce stress on est très encadré avec
l'équipe de France on n'est pas seul il
y a les autres les autres athlètes donc
c'est un soutien moi j'ai mes coachs qui
m'ont accompagné jusqu'en Croatie
Sandrine et Stéphane qui sont venus pour
me soutenir il y avait mon père il y
avait des amis des membres ici du club
qui sont venus aussi qui ont fait le
déplacement donc c'est un soutien de les
voir c'est une force
bien fermée
toplande pas sur ta jambe te plante pas
sur
le travail mais aussi un accompagnement
permanent depuis plus de 10 ans tout un
collectif se mobilise pour la soutenir
il y a vraiment un travail d'équipe
c'est à dire que elle est obligée
d'avoir des partenaires pour s'entraîner
et il y a vraiment un partenariat de
tout le monde c'est un sport qui qui
demande vraiment beaucoup de
d'implication pour beaucoup de monde
pour que Philippines y arrive voilà et
c'est il y a un travail d'elle-même mais
il y a aussi tout l'entourage qui compte
dans quelques jours Philippines
s'envolera pour le Liban avec une partie
de l'équipe de France l'occasion
d'améliorer encore ses performances et
de porter les couleurs de la France sans
oublier son club